- On garde nos lunettes tout
le temps. On les enlève pas.
On les enlève pas, on les enlève
quand on vous le dit.
- Un laser qui libère
autant d'énergie que
toute la production mondiale
d'électricité, de quoi
impressionner ces jeunes
étudiants en science
du secondaire qui visitent
de vrais laboratoires
pour la première fois.
- C'est intéressant.
Oui, c'est cool.
- J'aime beaucoup le fait qu'on
puisse apprendre la matière,
les plus petites particules,
la vitesse, c'est vraiment
tout ce qui est physique,
chimie, c'est vraiment
intéressant, je trouve.
- L'Institut national de
la recherche scientifique
accueille normalement
des étudiants à la maîtrise
ou au doctorat. Mais il veut
aussi stimuler l'intérêt
de jeunes qui sont encore
à plusieurs années de
leurs études supérieures.
FRANÇOIS LÉGARÉ,
professeur, INRS
- Oui, ils sont loin,
mais je me dis toujours :
Dans trois, quatre ans, ils vont
être... certains d'entre eux
vont aller à l'université.
Donc c'est une façon de se faire
connaître dans notre milieu,
puis sur 180 étudiants, je pense
qu'ils sont, même s'il y en
a quatre, cinq, six qui
reviennent, bien ça sera
déjà ça.
- On utilise des électrons au
lieu d'utiliser des photons...
- Mais il faut parfois couper
les cheveux en plusieurs
millions pour les stimuler.
- On coupe un petit cheveu,
pas besoin d'être beaucoup.
Ce qu'on va faire maintenant,
c'est de regarder le cheveu.
Ce qui est en bas du micron,
on appelle ça le?...
L'étape d'après, on appelle ça
le nanomètre.
- C'est vraiment le fun de voir
comment mon cheveu était,
dans le fond, en plus
qu'ils sont teints.
- C'est vraiment
de la technologie haute qu'on
voit pas dans les industries.
C'est juste ici qu'il y a ça.
Ça fait que c'est vraiment
impressionnant.
- Même la nourriture est
à base de science.
ALHEM MEZIADI, étud., doctorat,
sciences énergie et matériaux
- Aujourd'hui, je montre
aux étudiants la similarité
entre la cuisine moléculaire
et les systèmes de délivrance
des médicaments. Donc comment
on peut appliquer la science
et les réactions chimiques
dans notre cuisine.
- Ces jeunes allumés ont faim
de savoir, mais parfois aussi,
ils ont tout simplement faim.
Ici Michel Marsolais, Radio-Canada, Montréal